voilà je n'oublie pas que nous sommes à
pâques impossible de terminer ce journal
sans parler des oeufs ou des cloches
bref du chocolat la tradition demeure
mais vous allez le voir la mode évolue
car il ya maintenant même des chats ou
encore des pandas en chocolat marylène
bono pascal stelletta dans une fabrique
artisanale à puyricard
pour pas que les sujets en chocolat se
diversifie de plus en plus l'influencé
germanique cette année se fait sentir
avec l'arrivée sur le marché de beaucoup
d'animaux il ya des personnages qui sont
comment dirais-je depuis toujours dans
la mode de pacs dire les yeux les poules
la cloche et lapins même mais enfin
maintenant on y ajouter les petits chats
comme vous voyez des petits ours
ça plaît beaucoup aux enfants autre
nouveauté les grosses marbre et me
chocolat noir me chocolat blanc la
fabrication des moulages a commencé dès
fin février
ici 33 personnes fabrique plus de 16
mille sujets qui sont vendues en
quelques jours au moment de pâques
mais rien à voir avec la période des
fêtes de fin d'année où l'entreprise
réalise 42% de son chiffre d'affaires
contre 25 à 30% pour pâques
et puis autre particularité de cette
fabrication artisanale du chocolat
l'introduction de la crème fraîche un
bon chocolat c'est un chocolat qui est
fait frais avec des matières frêche sans
aucun ajout de produits de conservation
ni aucune autre adjuvant des synthèses
et si je vous demandais la définition
d'un bon chocolat d'un très bon chocolat
c'est de l'avoir fait avec amour
la fabrication du chocolat est une
véritable alchimie et c'est comme pour
la mode les tendances changent de plus
en plus les français préfèrent le
chocolat noir et son goût amer
pour moi ce sera juste un ours ou à la
rigueur à lapins